when i was young
i found an orphaned wolf cub in the
forest behind our farm
i felt if i could instill rules the
proper boundaries
i could harness
a few months later while hunting the
adolescent cub
turned on me
we're fixing the damage the avengers did
all those years ago
inhumans are sick unlimited power that's
dangerous it's lethal you
are lucky to be alive
come on kamala let aim help you
i'll take my chances
what if the avengers were set up i think
you should see for yourself
could it stark help us with this hi i'm
sorry who are you
uh kamala this better be good
she totally locked captain maria and
then he tried to
have you all completely lost your senses
what where were you while the world went
to hell
this is our fault all of ours
you really think the world is better
without us yes
see it's always been your problem
running from who you are
what you
you are against the unstoppable tide
of progress avengers
power cannot be controlled it has to be
destroyed
i will rid the earth of superpowers
even if it has to end with me
[Music]
what's up marvel fans my name is casey
lynch and i'm editorial director at
crystal dynamics
marvel's avengers war table is your
direct source
for all things marvel's avengers we've
got a great show lined up
with new trailers new details on one of
our main villains
modoc and advanced idea mechanics and
we'll take a first look at co-op and war
zones
if you've ever thought what is this game
or how does it work
then this is the show for you let's get
into it
starting with a story trailer in the
aftermath of a day
everything changed you so-called heroes
transformed san francisco
into an infectious gas-filled quarantine
zone
you unleash diseased powerful beings
that wreak havoc throughout our nation
so i ask you again
dr banner do the avengers pose a danger
to society
yes i can promise you this
[Music]
i will use this second chance
to make you safe aim
will find a cure for the inhuman disease
as a founding member of tech giant
advanced idea mechanics or aim
george tarleton dreamt of a world made
better through science
but even as aim promises a cure to end
the inhuman infection
and the revolutionary adaptoid project
offers a world protected by
science tarleton a victim of a day
himself
uses aims technological might and the
public's fear of inhumans to convince
the world
that the super-powered are
uncontrollable and cannot be trusted
his deranged obsession drives him to
become modoc
mental organism designed only for
killing
when choosing a villain we knew we
needed someone who had the muscle
and mental capacity to become an
avengers level threat
we also wanted a new face for modern
avengers fans
uh big face but comic fans know modoc is
anything but new
his origin in marvel lore dates back
more than 50 years to october
of 1967 in tales of suspense
now with ames strive to manipulate
public fear
and his ability to control machines with
his mind
tarleton and aim are the most
sophisticated threat the avengers have
ever faced
but a teenage fan girl named kamala khan
doesn't trust dame
in fact she's convinced that aim is
experimenting on her fellow and humans
under the guise of finding
a cure and she believes george tarleton
was behind the plot to discredit the
avengers and she has
proof as you pick up the trail of the
long disbanded avengers you'll advance
the story of the single player campaign
unlocking more and more hero specific
missions
we know you've been asking for new
gameplay that's not from a day
we hear you so here's a play through a
part of a new
thor hero mission called once an avenger
[Music]
uh
we're here live with the aim experience
in manhattan witnessing the return of
the avengers but they
they appear to be attacking the city
keep rolling keep rolling
is it any coincidence that this attack
comes on the very day that aim
is supposed to unveil their promising
new adaptoid program
you're welcome
thank you
[Music]
you should know i'm not in the best of
moves
wait is that thor holy crap thor
where the hell did you come from i was
serving the commoners when it started
raining bolts of metal from the skies
and it's unbelievably good to see you a
bit dramatic don't you think
it doesn't matter he's here
so now false god returns
why you did what you were supposed to do
thor you gave up your power
you should have stayed
are forgotten where do you hide doctor
can you not face me
what are these things they're drilling
into the deck
something carlson cooked up to crash the
chimera fun aren't they
oh hello
[Music]
just like old times
aim drop ships inbound i see them focus
on those mechs
kamala you okay yeah no
on my way hope you got this
dare i ask we'll explain later don't
worry she's up to it
chimera's still losing altitude so can
you hold it up with wind turn the ship
[Music]
apart
you killed captain america four who else
will fall before your hammer
[Music]
spotted again drones heading for the
command deck got my hands full kid
i'm on them
nice security subsystems just came back
online it's working
can you enable lockdown
[Music]
adventures
i can handle the large one myself you
don't have to
that's the whole point
guys the chimera can't take much more of
this they did a lot of damage down in
the engine room
do not do this you've given me no choice
[Music]
damage has already been done avengers
we're trying to restart the engines but
there's not enough power
we're out of time people brace for
impact
hey got a thunder stay behind me
now bring it
enjoy
[Music]
once an avenger is a great example of a
hero mission a single-player campaign
experience
focusing on a specific playable
character
hero missions give us a chance to tell
more of each hero's story
and showcase the variety and depth of
our hero designs
let's take a quick look at how thor
plays
with the game's combat systems players
can string together combos of heavy and
light attacks
or hold for signature attacks combat
versatility is one of thor's strengths
from making use of mjolnir to pin
enemies from a distance or bringing the
sky down on his foes
in addition to core combat moves the god
of thunder has a wide variety of skills
to unlock that give him access
to classic moves this is one of our
favorites
manual targeting we largely drew our
influence from writer jason aaron's run
on the mighty thor comic
manual targeting allows you to quickly
mark your enemies for bulls eyes with
mjolnir and one by one
you can mark them and knock them down as
milder comes back to you
follow that up with a powerful ground
pound and you've got a mighty combo
manual targeting is a great ranged
attack but if up close and personal is
more your style
go with the hammer spin or mule in your
cyclone
heroes have three special heroic moves
assault
ultimate and support
when designing our heroics we started
with the signature moves from the comics
and movies that we've always wanted to
play
the assault heroic charges the fastest
and in some cases you can store multiple
charges to use strategically as a part
of your combos you can perform these
after charging your heroic meters with
normal attacks
for instance natasha's assault heroic is
widow's bite
which is an electroshock projectile move
you might recognize
you can see matt using it right here
each hero also has a unique support
heroic that's designed to enhance
co-op and team play for example
thor's support warriors fury lets him
channel the power of the gods
to supercharge his odin force and grants
a period of invulnerability for nearby
team members
you can see this in action when iron man
gets the buff as he flies
through thor's support
ultimates take longer to charge but
they're definitely worth the wait
they have more screen clearing power and
some even have residual effects
like thor's bifrost ultimate thor's
ultimate heroic channels the power of
the nine realms and his bifrost taps
into muspelheim
to bypass unbreakable shields allowing
thor to use the power of the bifrost
bridge
to do maximum damage
we know everyone plays differently so we
have melee
ranged aerial and ground combat skills
to tailor your hero to your play style
as your heroes are an experience they
gain access to new skills
skill points allow you to unlock new
moves combos
and even new versions of attacks
as you build up your heroes you begin to
see how unlocking and mastering the
separate core skills
offers a ton of depth and variety on its
own for every hero
and that's before gear perks artifacts
and any kind of later game progression
so why is all of this important because
it means your thor will play differently
than my thor
and my hulk will play different than
yours
another way to customize your heroes is
with gear we've previously talked about
the different rarities and how perks
will give you powerful modifiers for
even more customization
some perks apply special damage like
plasma or gamma
or cause status effects like shrink
which will shrink
enemies and reduce damage and defense
you can see iron man using gamma gear in
this shot and eagle-eyed fans probably
noticed his laser sweep was green
instead of red nope that wasn't a bug
when you have gamma gear equipped it
grants a bonus damage modifier and
changes the emissive color of your
attack
and voila green lasers
we know that if you look good you'll
play good the crystal team has really
enjoyed creating all new outfits for
these heroes
and drawing from marvel's 80-year
history to bring so many classic outfits
to the game
each hero has dozens of outfits drawn
from some of the most
recognizable eras and story arcs
you can earn them over the course of the
story campaign by completing missions
and deciphering patterns
there's iron man suit from the 2014
original sins
storyline or donald blake which is a nod
to an
alias of thor's who first appeared in
1962's journey into mystery issue 83
or tony's star tech outfit that was
inspired by the bleeding edge armor that
first appeared in
invincible iron man number 25 in 2010.
while there are a ton of outfits you'll
earn just by playing some will require
completing iconic mission chains to earn
each hero's iconic outfit
and some outfits will only be available
in our online marketplace
you can even customize your attitude and
let out your inner hulk with the right
emote
i don't think that's canon
those are just some of the ways you'll
be able to build and spec out your
heroes
okay i think it's time for another
trailer this one gives us a first look
at how all that customization is
especially fun
when you play together this is co-op
and war zones
i can't believe it the aim is firing on
the air force
they said tap toys of his they harvest
their powers through the torture of
these inhumans georgie boy is gearing up
for war
programmable power under our control no
more heroes
the entire world is in terrible danger
time is here i could pull some strings
to spruce up the armory get ourselves
some new toys to play with
dangerous ones
[Music]
magic
we gotta get this bird in the air before
aim comes looking for us
jarvis is unencrypting the schematics
and we'll get our tech heads on new gear
[Music]
asap
[Music]
heroes
if i don't stop them it's just one more
thing to regret on my deathbed
you want to see powers here we go
time for heroes is over you
don't get to decide who lives
hey
so far we've talked about the story hero
missions and customization
now let's talk about war zones
war zones are missions which you can
play with up to a total of four players
or solo with an ai companion team made
up of your unlocked and leveled heroes
whether playing hero missions or war
zones you always make forward progress
with your heroes
on your helicarrier you'll use the war
table to launch missions with a variety
of objectives and challenges
as you saw on the co-op trailer each
mission is grounded in story
so whether you're in the campaign or war
zones you're always working together to
stop
aim and rebuild the resistance you get
missions from jarvis
maria hill hank pym and more characters
from marvel history
once you pick your mission you'll board
the quinjet where you can match make
switch heroes choose your loadout and of
course
pick the right look and attitude for the
job
as you start playing missions across the
globe you'll realize aim has entrenched
themselves in cities and remote
locations alike
all in the name of research
war zones range from wide open spaces
designed for exploration and team
traversal
to dense interiors with a variety of
objective-based challenges
boss fights and rewards here's a mission
we saw on the co-op trailer called
to tame a titan where we can see some
team play
there's this cool shot of iron man but
you may have missed kamala and hulk
performing a team finisher
on that poor guy back there when you max
out some larger enemies stun
meter two heroes can come together to
perform a team finisher
which gives you a chance to take them
down much faster
teamwork makes the dream work living the
hero life is all about growth
getting stronger and better equipped to
play smarter and there are plenty of
upgrades to help you do
just that as you progress through the
campaign you'll also be rebuilding and
upgrading the chimera
your helicarrier which is your own
flying base
the resistance is a group who have
banded together in the five years since
a day
some are inhuman and have powers some
are former shield agents who refuse to
pledge allegiance to aim
and some just want to help
what is this place we call it the ant
hill
not my idea you'll join their cause in
the field by working directly with
factions
like the inhuman alliance and shield
agents dum dum dugen
nick fury and more earning faction
reputation will give you access to new
challenges hey avengers hill has
something she needs your help with
new vendors and more powerful items
there will always be new threats on the
horizon so you want to ensure
your avengers are ready for anything
we've talked about a lot today but
that's kind of the point
this is a really big ambitious game
marvel's avengers isn't just a global
high-stakes race
to rebuild the avengers to save the
inhumans and uncover the truth about
ames plans
that's just the beginning this is a
brand new original avengers single
player story
that you can enjoy on your own made the
crystal dynamics way
but it's also an experience you can play
with your friends that will grow as we
add new heroes
new regions and new story all at no
additional cost
thank you for following us and believing
in us i want to give a big shout out to
our community
thank you for caring and telling us what
you think we're listening
and as fans ourselves we're all working
every day to make marvel's avengers
worthy of your support please stick
around after the show to ask questions
and chat
on behalf of the whole marvel's avengers
team thank you for tuning in to the
first
marvel's avengers war table in the
coming months we'll talk about our first
post-launch hero our upcoming beta
and of course our launch when marvel's
avengers arrives
september 4th
[Music]
i'm casey lynch and i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you